[Musique]
bonjour Stéphane piénoir B merci
beaucoup de nous accompagner pendant
cette première demi-heure vous êtes élu
de menéloir membre du groupe les
républicains membres de la commission de
la culture et de l'éducation va pas mal
parler de ces sujets d'abord un mot plus
général sur cette semaine politique et
ce rendez-vous avec la nation d'Emmanuel
Macron entre le remaniment et sa grande
conférence de presse il a réussi son
rendez-vous pour vous en s'agissant du
la grande conférence de presse le grand
rendez-vous avec les Français moi ce que
j'en ai retenu c'est surtout la longueur
enfin 3h beaucoup trop long et on a
l'impression que c'est interminable que
ça n'a pas de faim 3h pour convaincre
que tout va bien dans le pays c'est que
forcément il y a un petit problème euh
voilà on sait qu'Emmanuel Macron aime
beaucoup s'écouter euh c'est ce qu'il a
fait c'est ce qu'il a produit mardi soir
pour finalement assez peu de mesures
concrètes
euh des grands plans des choses qui
étaient déjà prévues sur le je pense au
plan
contre l'infertilité c'était déjà
quelque chose qui était inscrit dans la
loi biotique de 2021 et il y a pas de
plan aujourd'hui donc on reprend on
reprend des choses on donne l'impression
qu'on qu'on fait du neuf avec du vieux
on évoque la généralisation et
l'obligation du SNU dans un délai qu'on
ne connaît pas dans quelles conditions
l'hébergement enfin c'est un flou
généralisé mais trop loin des
préoccupations des Français mais lui est
très satisfait de sa prestation c'est
peut-être l'essentiel finalement trop
loin des préoccupations des Français pas
assez précis en fait et on a besoin
d'avoir des enfin on a un chef de
l'exécutif on a besoin d'avoir une ligne
claire d'avoir un cadre des choses
précise pas pas du vent pendant 3h il a
donné une place importante à l'éducation
avec certaines mesures la l'uniforme à
l'école qui sera expérimenté en 2024
pour une possible généralisation en 2026
il s'est dit favorable à l'apprentissage
de la Marseillaise au primaire au
renforcement des cours d'éducation
civique ça peut apparaître comme dé
marqueurs de droite est-ce qu'il vous a
convaincu
oui alors sur vous savez alors c'est des
ou non seulement c'est des marqueurs de
droite mais c'est des propositions qui
ont été faites par le groupe les
républicain ici au Sénat et et même à
l'Assemblée nationale mais et à ce
moment-là on nous taxè de d'extrémistes
ou de de nationalistes quand on évoque
la Marseillaise l'obligation de de
pouvoir chanter la Marseillaise pour
pour les jeunes euh aujourd'hui c'est à
la mode donc on reprend ça puis ça ça
devient à la mode parce que c'est
Emmanuel Macron qui le dit donc
évidemment je vais pas je vais pas dire
le contraire aujourd'hui sur
sur le MC sur l'éducation morale et
civique j'avais produit un rapport il y
a il y a 2 ans suite à une mission sur
comment réveiller la la citoyenneté des
jeunes avec le constat de l'abstention
extrêmement importante chez les jeunes
et ça faisait partie de des
préconisations très fortes de dire il
faut balayer parce que l'éducation
morale et civique c'est l'exemple type
de ce qu'on demande à l'école
aujourd'hui c'est-à-dire tout on met au
fur et à mesure des textes c'està le
législateur est en grande partie
responsable on on ajoute on surrajoute
des sensibilisations au développement
durable au bien-être animal tout ça des
choses qui en elles-même sont évidemment
importantes mais avec une demi-heure de
cours par semaine et on réalise pas donc
al je sais qu'aujourd'hui on est capable
de faire en plus des cours d'empathie
c'est un autre sujet mais l'éducation
morale et civique il faut revenir aux
fondamentaux c'est-à-dire le
fonctionnement des institutions
qu'est-ce que c'est qu'un maire
qu'est-ce que c'est que des des
parlementaires et cetera ça on y est
évidemment favorable et vous vous
parliez du flou tout à l'heure la il y a
des cours d'éducation civique il y a
aussi des cours de théâtre puisqu'il
veut des cours de théâtre au collège
quand on sait qu'il y a des pénuries de
professeurs des millions d'heur qui sont
perdu est-ce que pour vous ce sont des
promesses tenables est-ce que c'était la
priorité non bien sûr que c'était pas la
priorité moi je évidemment que l'art la
culture c'est important et que je je
comprends bien le le ressort de tout ça
c'est-à-dire de développer l'expression
à l'oral des jeunes parce qu'on sait que
c'est une c'est une problématique dans
notre pays n nos jeunes ne sont pas
suffisamment entraînés à s'exprimer
souvent le premier oral qui passe c'est
c'est au bac au moment du bac bon ok
mais le passage obligatoire dès le
collège enfin sont des des gamins il y a
beaucoup de timidité il y a aussi
beaucoup de beaucoup de NIS beaucoup de
moqueries entre entre jeunes de cet âge
là c'est compliqué de se de s'exposer
alors peut-être que ça pour certains ça
peut être une bonne une bonne thérapie
si je peux dire mais le rendre
obligatoire non c'était pas la priorité
et puis je me demande là encore où on va
trouver les les heures Emmanuel Macron
n'a pas réformé le calendrier ni le
volume horaire il y a toujours 24 heures
par jour il pas annoncer de réforme dans
ce dans ce domaine là donc il faut faire
avec quoi donc arrêtons de de surajouter
des des des des nécessité un petit des
priorités partout revenons aux vraies
priorités qui
sont le français les mathématiques
l'histoire géo par exemple il a soutenu
à Amélie ou Casteras sa ministre de
l'éducation nationale dans la polémique
sur la justification de la scolarisation
de ses enfants dans le privé est-ce que
pour vous la page est tournée est-ce
qu'elle va pouvoir travailler
sereinement avec les syndicats
sereinement ça me paraît difficile je je
connais un petit peu aussi le milieu
enseignant et le milieu syndical pour
l'avoir côtoyé pendant pendant 25 ans
dans dans ma carrière je pense qu'ils
vont pas lâcher comme ça
mais le président de la République a
pointé une maladresse c'est un peu plus
que ça quand même parce que le choix
personnel d'un foyer de d'inscrire ses
enfants dans le public ou le privé il
faut pas qu'on on ressorte la guerre des
des écoles entre l'école publi et
l'école privée c'est c'est leur choix et
là-dessus j'aimerais que personne ne le
conteste moi je suis dans un département
vous savez dans dans dans certaines
communes il n'y a que des écoles privées
ce serait une aberration de dire on va
forcément construire une école publique
à côté voilà je pense qu'il faut
enterrer cette cette hache de
guerre maintenant la justification
qu'elle a donné elle est plus que
maladroite elle est contredite par un
certain nombre d'acteurs
l'institutrice des elle est mensongère
ben oui en fait la dernière sortie en
disant je n'ai pas menti mais la réalité
m'a donné tort je je comprends pas enfin
là encore c'est des éléments de langage
que moi je je n'ai pas donc oui elle est
chahuté ça va être compliqué le le monde
enseignant c'est c'est une grosse
machine c'est une grosse structure elle
va avoir du mal à se à se remettre sur
sur de bons rail si je puux dire et puis
au-delà de ça de toute façon pour moi
une erreur de de périmètre ben oui parce
que l'année où on organise les Jeux
Olympiques si on n pas une ministre à
pleintemps sur le sport enfin je sais
pas quelle année on va pouvoir le faire
c'est c'est c'est une fois par siècle
l'éducation nationale c'est le premier
budget de l'État euh les les défis sont
immenses sur on a aussi besoin d'un
ministre à pleintemps donc là je je
comprends pas ce périmètre sauf à
vouloir faire de l'affichage à dire oui
on a un gouvernement hyper resserré
jusqu'à pas opportun jusqu'à la
nomination des des ministres délégués
secrétaires d'État qui vont compléter
tout ça dans dans dans quelques jours un
mot sur Stanislas qui est donc
l'établissement privé dans lequel elle a
mis ses enfants qui est dans le 6e
arrondissement de Paris il y a un
rapport qui dénonce des dérives dans
l'application du contrat d'association
ce rapport a été dévoilé par miaap alors
qu'il a été bouclé en août est-ce que
pour vous c'est un problème est-ce que
le Sénat va se pencher sur cette
question alors c'est un rapport
d'inspection he pour bien comprendre
donc il faut que ça remonte de manière
hiérarchique sur à l'éducation nationale
donc c'est arrivé sur le bureau du
ministre de l'époque donc Gabriel Atal
qui s'en est saisi on peut on ne peut
pas dire qu'il ne s'est rien passé il y
a eu un des préconisations donc moi on
n' pas connaissance de ça en tant que
parlementaire effectivement ça peut être
une demande notamment de la commission
culture à laquelle j' apptient de se
dire mais d'abord l'intégralité du
rapport ensuite les préconisations là
aujourd'hui on on se base sur des
extraits de de
médiap plus de 6 mois après la livraison
au moment opportun donc de la nomination
d'une nouvelle ministre bon tout cela on
voit bien est aussi un petit peu piloté
bon n'empêche que il y a des éléments un
faisceau d'indice comme on dit qui qui
nous font penser qu'il y a tout n'est
pas respecté dans cet établissement
notamment la la neutralité religieuse
c'est-à-dire l'obligation euh qui est
constatée d'avoir du catchs pour les
pour les les jeunes de cet établissement
ça n'est pas conforme lorsqu'on est dans
un contrat d'association avec l'État
hein ça veut dire que ça ça donne des
garanties le paiement des des salaires
par l'État mais mais évidemment il y a
des il y a des contraintes et ces
contraintes notamment la la la garantie
mais ça veut dire que le Sénat vous
aimeriez que le Sénat fasse la lumière
là-dessus oui par exemple on peut très
bien je je sais que hier soir Paris a
suspendu sa euh la subvention le
financement de de Stanislas il faut
qu'on y voit clair enfin avant de
prendre des décisions moi j'aimerais
bien qu' qu'on y voit clair parce
qu'encore une fois on raisonne sur des
sur des extraits qui sont un peu
orientés forcément c'est quand Mme Médi
part faut quand même le rappeler mais il
y a aussi alors sur les propos
homophobes des des des individus des des
enseignants là sont vraiment des des
traitements disciplinaires qu'on doit
avoir ça n'engage pas pour moi le
l'établissement tout entier on va parler
justement de l'actualité au Sénat
puisque hier soir avait lueu un débat
sur les violences dans le le foot à
l'intérieur et à l'extérieur des stades
débat auquels vous avez participé
Stéphane Piednoir on fait le point tout
de suite avec notre journaliste
parlementaire Samia
[Musique]
docher bonjour Samia bonjourien bonjour
Stéphan pi bonjour et Samia vous avez
suivi avec attention ce débat hier soir
au Sénat sur les violences dans le foot
auquel participait notamment Stéphane
pienor oui c'est un débat qui a été
demandé par le groupe Union centriste au
Sénat alors pourquoi maintenant et bien
parce que la fin de l'année 2023 a été
marqué par plusieurs actes de violence
grave avec bien sûr le cillassage du bus
de l'Olympique Lyonnais à Marseille fin
octobre on se souvient des images de
Fabio Grosso l'entraîneur de l'OL le né
en sang à la une des journaux et puis
les insultes racistes les les racistes
les Salus naasis et les crit de singe
lancé enryost par certains lyonnais qui
ont beaucoup choqué et puis le 2
décembre le décès d'un supporter du FC
Nantes tué dans une al cation avec un
chauffeur de VTC après un match avec
Nice avec Nice alors vu le contexte le
gouvernement avait décidé en décembre
dernier d'un moratoire sur les
déplacements de supporters pour les
matchs à risque en Ligue 1 ce moratoire
aujourd'hui il a pris fin mais il a été
très mal vécu par les clubs de
supporters et hier les sénatrices et
sénateurs ont presque tous critiqué
aussi cette mesure regardez
l'intervention de Claude
kerneide de l'individualisation des
peine madame la ministre la France s'est
focalisé ces dernières années sur les
mesures d'interdiction collective et
beaucoup moins sur les interdictions
individuelles on ne comptait en France
que 218 personnes interdites de stade en
juillet 2023 contre quelques 1600 en
Angleterre et 1300 en Allemagne selon un
expert du supporterisme est-ce que selon
vous la France a fait une erreur en
interdisant les déplacements de clubs
entiers sur les matchs les plus à risque
en décembre oui c'est vraiment ça qui a
été remis en cause lors du débat hier et
plus généralement lorsqu'on on échange
avec les clubs de supporters euh et
parfois d'ailleurs ces interdictions
elles se font quelques heures avant le
début du match c'est c'est c'est
incompréhensible pour des matchs de
Coupe d'Europe on a on a vu ça des des
des placacements je crois de d'un d'un
club espagnol euh qui était euh qui
était qui se rendait à Lille je me
semble-t-il et au dernier moment on leur
dit oui alors peut-être que vous allez
pouvoir rentre c'est pas possible de
raisonner comme ça il faut qu'on ait des
interdictions euh au cas par cas c'est
c'est ce qu'a fait l'Angleterre vous
savez l'Angleterre a connu une grande
crise du higanisme dans les années 80 90
avec des plus que des incidents des
drames majeurs dans dans dans leur stade
ils ont pris des dispositions
d'interdictions de stade individuel et
en quoi c'est plus efficace que des
interdictions collectives de déplacement
pour des clubs entiers parce que la
punition est collective et et il faut
toujours avoir en tête l'effet de loupe
quand vous dites que le le club le le
car de Lyon a été caillassé mais c'est
quoi c'est quelques individus c'est
quelques dizaines d'individus tout au
plus qui nuisent à plusieurs milliers
dizaines de milliers de supporters donc
moi je cette cette idée de sanction
collective alors que on a
quelques quelques malades qui qui qui
font n'importe quoi aux abords des
stades et dans les stades on a des
moyens aujourd'hui pour identifier
vraiment de manière très précises les
auteurs à la fois à l'extérieur de stade
mais encore plus dans les stades tout
est il y a des caméras partout tout est
filmé on peut très bien développer ça je
parlais de l'Angleterre mais le
holiganisme était vraiment un fléo qui
qui menaçait chaque match à l'époque
ils ont pris des vraiment des mesures
très très fortes et aujourd'hui il y a
encore 1500 interdit de stade mais
c'était beaucoup plus il y a quelques
années on est sur une phase vraiment
descendante il y a une autre politique
qui était d'augmenter fortement le prix
des places de stade et et ça très
critiqué d' et qui est très critiquer
évidemment si vous voulez voir un match
à Arsenal aujourd'hui c'est hors de prix
mais donc on veut éviter ça mais
néanmoins on veut se donner les moyens
ça on a progressé depuis les années 80
on a des moyens techniques pour
identifier les les auteurs de ces les
interdictions c'est quoi c'est c'est la
solution de faciliter le le truc le le
la chose la plus simple pour parce qu'on
sait pas gérer finalement ces
déplacement de groupe de suppors ouais
ça donne cette impression là et puis et
puis plus globalement enfin je pense que
falloir qu'on s'interroge un jour sur la
culture de ce foot quoi de ce de ce
sport pourquoi on n pas ce type de
réaction ce type de manifestation dans
des stades qui sont tout aussi pleins
pour des matchs de rugby on n'entend pas
parler de ce genre de choses sur des
matchs de hand pourtant un sport
extrêmement virile de tact ou de basket
ou je ne sais quoi il y a un problème de
il a il y a une culture du respect qui
n'existe pas dans le foot et on en
parlait tout à l'heure ça commence par
le terrain ça commence par le refus de
de contester moi il y a une règle que
j'adore au rugby c'est celle qui qui qui
qui dit qu'à partir du moment où il y a
une pénalité qui est sifflée par
l'arbitre s'il y a le moindre joueur qui
vient contester la décision la pénalité
est conservée mais 5 m plus loin et on
progresse comme ça jusqu'à
éventuellement accorder un essai faut
faire ça dans le foot bien sûr on peut
faire ça et on arrive jusqu'à la zone de
surface ça fait penalty et pourquoi pas
on peut s'inspirer de ce qui fonctionne
quand il y a une bagarre sur un terrain
de rugby l'arbitre laisse les grands
garçons se bagarrer pendant quelques
minutes et ensuite il distribu les
sanctions dit vous êtes vous êtes grand
ok mais derrière il y aura des sanctions
prenez vos responsabilités alors Amélie
oua cterra en tout cas hier soir elle a
maintenu he que cet outil d'interdiction
collective des déplacements de
supporters il reste nécessaire à ses
yeux pour les matchs les plus à risque
mais elle a quand même dit aussi qu'elle
voulait à tout prix l'éviter he qu'elle
ferait tout à l'avenir pour cadrer les
déplacements plutôt que les interdire
alors comment veut-elle s'y prendre elle
a annoncé hier que le gouvernement
allait bientôt dévoiler un plan de lutte
contre les violences dans le football un
plan qui prévoirait notamment une
meilleure anticipation des rencontres en
mettant tous les acteurs concernés
autour de la table un point me paraît
absolument crucial c'est la manière dont
nous préparons les rencontres de
football en préfecture avec les
directeurs sûreté et sécurité des clubs
avec les référents supporters avec les
référents les policiers référents
supporters visiteurs ça c'est clé et on
le voit à chaque fois que le dialogue se
nous dans ces instances là avec
suffisamment d'anticipation nous
trouvons des solutions pour quasiment à
chaque fois éviter les interdictions de
déplacement de supporter mais au
contraire mettre au point un encadrement
de ces déplacements qui lui est beaucoup
plus constructif partagé attendu par les
acteurs est-ce que la France est en
retard dans la préparation de ces matchs
pour anticiper les violences en mettant
tous les acteurs autour d'une table oui
visiblement on est en retard des choses
sont sont organisées hein effectivement
avec le les réunions en préfecture 3
semaines avant un match 3 4 jours avant
enfin on voit aussi à quel point ça
mobilise les forces de de police de de
gendarmerie des pompiers les la
préfecture elle-même puis une nouvelle
réunion 3 jours avant qui à ce moment-là
peut décider de classer une une réunion
une une rencontre à risque enfin j'ai en
tête la dernière grosse bagarere entre
supporter à anger au SC d'Anger avec des
des supporters de camp enfin si Angers
camp est devenu une affiche à risque
dans notre championnat de de de Ligue 2
en l'occurrence ou de Ligue 1 peu
importe il y a quand même quelque chose
qui va pas on connaît les les rivalités
historiques entre Marseille et Paris par
exemple bon ok là on sa mais si si un
camp anger devient un match à risque on
va pas y arriver quoi et ça et tout ça
ça déteint sur le monde amateur donc je
je crois qu'il faut vraiment qu'on
traite à la racine par un ch chement
dans les dans les règles de ce foot qui
est devenu beaucoup trop laxiste parce
que on autorise n'importe quel joueur
ferrati par exemple qui joue plus en
francef qui est l'archétype du joueur
qui conteste toute décision de l'arbitre
faut qu'on arrête avec ça Samia vous
parliez de ce grand plan que va annoncer
le gouvernement plan de lutte contre les
violences dans le foot quelles sont les
autres mesures envisagées alors on
connaî pas encore le contenu de ce plan
Orian mais il suscite déjà des craintes
plusieurs sénateurs se sont inquiétés
hier de voir les règles se durcir au
point que que les stades deviennent
asceptisés sans l'ambiance qui est mise
par les clubs de de supporters alors sur
ce point la ministre s'est quand même
voulu rassurante et à évoquer quelques
pistes regardez il est important de pas
faire d'amalgame entre ce supporteurisme
le plus passionnel exacerbé et d'un
autre côté les actes de violence nous
avons fait en sorte qu'il y ait une
vraie place pour le supporterisme dans
le respect des lois de la République
nous l'avons construite cette réponse
dans le cadre d'un dialogue avec les
associations de supporter au sein de
l'INS plusieurs initiatives concrètes à
la clé l'expérimentation des tribunes
debout la généralisation des référents
supporters et la mise en place des
policiers référents supporters visiteurs
pour améliorer l'organisation des déplac
est-ce que vous aussi vous craignez
Stéphane piernoir qu'un encadrement trop
poussé des clubs de supporters ne tue
l'ambiance dans les stades oui c'est
évident alors le sénateur Levy évoquéit
hier une proposition du d'un d'un
président de club qui qui qui qui vise à
à mêler les les les clubs de supporters
entre eux malheureusement j'ai envie de
dire on en est pas rendu là parce que il
faut aujourd'hui encore un peu de
discipline et encore une séparation oui
ça acptise un peu et puis ça on voit
bien qu'on on est bloc contre bloc c'est
ces clubs de de supporters sont parqués
dans des zones parfois assez proches ça
n'empêche pas les jet de projectiles
parfois des ils arrivent à se fondre
dessus euh bon on attend évidemment les
les les décisions de ce plan d'action
qui a été qui a été annoncé par la
ministre hier on peut aussi s'interroger
sur les obligations pour les clubs il
une obligation de résultats aujourd'hui
il y a pas d'obligation de moyens c'est
qu'on ne contrôle pas ce qui est mis en
place par chaque club amateur y compris
pour contrer ça il doit y avoir une
politique contre les les insultes les
menaces enfin tout ce qui dégénère
autour du du match et dans le match
alors vous parlez des clubs amateurs et
justement le football amateur n'est pas
du tout épargné par les violence et hier
plusieurs sénatrices et sénateurs ont
proposé la signature obligatoire d'une
charte éthique pour tous les clubs une
char une charte pour bannir le racisme
l'homophobie est-ce que ce serait
vraiment efficace et
suffisant et charart vous savez moi
j'étais quand j'étais rapporteur sur le
texte principe de la République on nous
a on nous a avancé ça en disant regardez
mais il y a pas de problème toutes les
associations vont signer une charte et
on va lutter avec ça contre le
séparatisme bon ça c'est un petit bout
de papier qui peut qui peut satisfaire
pendant un temps mais mais je pense
qu'il faut des mesures beaucoup plus
draconiennes que ça parce que parce que
le mal est et là est profond et qu'il
faut comme je disais tout à l'heure
vraiment prendre des des mesures très
strictes d'interdiction individuelles et
et pas pour des pas pour quelques matchs
parfois c'est une interdiction sur 3
semaines non y compris dans le foot
amateur ah mais bien sûr bien sûr c'est
ce qui s'est passé d'ailleurs dans les
incidents dans dans mon département
qu'on va évoquer je crois ou tout de
suite merci Samia merci Orian à tout à
l'heure pour nous parler du d'une autre
actualité hier au Sénat des premers pas
du gouvernement Atal aux questions
d'actualité du Sénat ce sera ass tout à
l'heure dans le club à tout à l'heure ça
bien on va effectivement continuer à
parler de ce sujet des violences dans le
sport Stéphane piennoir puisque ça fait
aussi la une de la presse régionale et
notamment dans votre département où on
va aller où on retrouve Frédéric Barry
bonjour merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
rédacteur en chef du Courrier de l'Ouest
Frédéric Le Journal du Mané Loir le C de
l'Est et comme les autres titres de la
presse régionale on le disait bien placé
pour observer ces phénomènes de violence
sur les terrains de foot oui sur le
terrain et et en dehors puisque chaque
weekend nos journalistes et nom
correspondant couvre des des matchs de
football professionnel mais aussi euh
amateur ou dans des villages où le club
parfois c'est la seule animation hein le
le dimanche et parfois effectivement
comme vous l'avez dit des débordements
sont observés euh l'histoire à laquelle
fait allusion le sénateur Piednoir elle
s'est passée à à lauré d'Anjou c'était
tout début octobre et à l'origine
visiblement des insulteurs racistes tout
cela s'est terminé par quatre blessés
dont deux jeunes de 16 ans qui ont été
euh transporté à l'hôpital et puis le
même type de situation se rencontre dans
le départements voisins en en Sarte le
weekend dernier sur la commune d'allon
un match qui ét interrompu par l'arbitre
euh à la mi-temps en Loir Atlantique
également et ces situations est-ce
qu'elles font l'objet de suite
oui bah le sénateur il faisait allusion
euh peu de temps après lesffit à
lauréanjou le le président euh du club
visiteur le quartier d'Anger qui était
également joueur dans cette rencontre
euh dénonçit des insultes racistes dans
les colonnes du du Courrier de l'Ouest
et il accusait le cor adverse d'être à
l'origine de l'altercation euh il
stigmatisait hein les propos qui euh
sont souvent proférés sur les sur les
terrains à l'encontre à l'encontre de de
son équipe c'était parole contre parole
et euh finalement son club à l'origine
de de l'échau fourouré a été lourdement
sanctionné huit match de suspension don
dont deux avec surcis 100 € d'Amand pour
un joueur un enferme de de suspension
sportive pour un autre euh et 1200 €
d'amende pour pour le club alors une
amende plus modeste a été prise à
l'encontre de l'autre club concerné
Frédéric comment on explique ces actes
qui peuvent paraître incompréhensibles
dans des matchs si vous le disiez
Stéphane piernoir n'ont pas forcément un
énorme en
jeu vous avez un petit peu tout dit en
fait le débardement à Marseille lors de
laavenue de Lyon avec le caillassage du
bus de l'équipe adverse donc les
événements dramatiques avec la mort d'un
supporter en marche d'une rencontre à
Nant cette multiplication d'
dans le monde du football professionnel
ce n'est pas sans conséquence pour les
clubs amateurs à anger une violente
bagarre a eu lieu entre supporter ultra
d'Anger et du du SCO et de camp pardon
dans un bar du centreville c'était le le
27 novembre dernier et le président de
club que nous que nous interrogeons de
club amateur tire la sonnette
d'alarme la violence du monde
professionnel j'ai envie de dire
ruisselle vers le football amateur
pourtant jamais ces clubs n'ont été
aussi bien organisés structurés avec le
recrutementah d'éducateurs salariés la
mise en place de programme de
sensibilisation l'obtention de label et
le district lui a a deux axes pour agir
la prévention à la fois dans les stades
et sur les réseaux sociaux et la
sanction mais on voit bien que ce n'est
pas toujours suffisant l'enjeu est
important puisque dans sa dans sa dans
sa vie un jeune français sur tro passera
par un club de football vous avez une
question Frédéric pour Stéphane piernoir
ou je le laisse réagir à ce que vous ven
dire mais j'ai envie de demander à
Monsieur Piednoir comment les
fédérations sportive et notamment la
Fédération Française de Football
réagisse-elle à à cette cette démarche
cette démarche
parlementaire la démarche parlementaire
du débat d'hier soir c'est absolument
oui al on a pas de réaction encore c'est
c'est c'est très chaud he c'était hier
soir mais enfin vous avez tout à fait
raison c'est la culture par l'exemple
sur le terrain et qu'est-ce qu'on voit
quel est le le vecteur qu'est-ce qui
rejaillit sur les gamins qui veulent
jouer au foot dès le plus jeune âge ce
sont les pros ce sont les pros qui
donnent le mauvais exemple parfois
aujourd'hui quand ils font 10 roulades
d'affilé parce qu'ils ont été frôés pour
essayer de gagner un penalty fa il faut
qu'on il faut qu'on ait des règles
beaucoup plus strictes de sur le terrain
et je parle pas forcément de de de
carton rouge parce qu'en début d'année
la la Fédération a toujours un un
discours très ferme en disant vous allez
voir là le la moindre altercation enfin
le moindre tirage de maillot dans la
surface ce sera penalty et cetera c'est
pas de ça qu'on c'est pas de ça qu'on
parle il peut y avoir des des fautes
dans le foot c'est un sport de contact
il faut pas il faut pas rier ça
néanmoins par contre les comportements
humains qui
sont qui sont négatifs et qui
rejaillissent ensuite sur les gamins
c'est ça qu'il faut combattre et on doit
avoir des mesures disciplinaires une
simulation peut être accompagnée je sais
pas moi d'une exclusion temporaire ça
existe au hand on a le championnat
d'Europe qui se produit en ce moment de
de de hand ball il y a des des des des
sorties pour 2 minutes quand vous êtes à
un joueur de moins
pendant 2 minutes ça ça se voit au foot
on peut très bien imaginer une
suspension temporaire d'une exclusion
temporaire d'un joueur pour quelques
minutes 5 10 minutes et et s'il y en a
deux ou trois à faire des simulations en
même temps je pense que ça ça va
commencer à poser ça revient à ce que
vous disiez tout à l'heure s'inspirer
des autres sports pour changer les
règles du jeu dans le foot merci merci
beaucoup Frédérique on regarde la une du
Courrier de l'Ouest future prison danger
le projet refu revu et corrigé pardon
c'est à la Une de votre journal ce matin
merci beaucoupé Barry d'avoir été avec
nous un un dernier mot pour parler d'un
autre sujet des JO c'est un rapport
évidemment toujours avec le sport
puisque vous avez auditionné également
hier Michel Cado le délégué
interministériel à ses Jeux Olympiques
on est à un tout petit peu plus de 6
mois maintenant du début de cgio est-ce
que vous avez encore des
inquiétudes bon le message à la fois
était quand même globalement rassurant
on av également Nicolas Ferrand qui est
le directeur général de solideo qui est
chargé des des infrastructures des 70
ouvrages qui sont donc livrés ou en
cours de livraison finalisé donc très
rassurant sur le timing les équipements
sont prêts et comme toujours en fait il
y a un peu de panique dans les derniers
mois mais ça ce sera prêt sur le la
trajectoire financière là aussi un
message rassurant mais comme on regarde
un petit peu dans le détail on pose des
questions nous vous savez quand on est
parlementaire donc là il y a 17 millions
supplémentaires cette année donc c'est
c'est à la marge sur un budget je vous
rappelle de de 4 milliards 4 bon mais il
avait augmenté de 400 millions l'an der
et globalement depuis le début de la
l'annonce de la candidature c'est 15 %
supplémentaire bon donc il y a il y a un
impact néanmoins il y a ce fameux cette
fameuse réserve que la Cour des comptes
avait exigé d'au moins 100 millions il y
a 120 millions de réserves pour les
fonds publics pour financer le le reste
mais oui bon puis quelque chose qui doit
être enthousiasment bon c'est quand même
un événement qu'on organise comme je
disais tout à l'heure une fois par
siècle il faut que ce soit une grande
fête et ce qui est assez formidable dans
le la conception de tout ça c'est
l'héritage des jeux c'est-à-dire qu'on
voit bien que sur les 70 ouvrages 49
sont en scè saint le village des
athlètes 15000 athlètes qui seront
accueillis on voit que ça ça ça va
transformer Saint-Denis saintouin et
l'île Saint-Denis avec plus de 6000
habitants qui vont arriver à terme donc
ça va vraiment donner un coup de boost à
ce département qu'on a bien besoin sur
l'accueil et on en revient à la question
des supporters est-ce que les leçons du
fiasco de la finale de la Ligue des
Champions été tiré est-ce qu'il ne se
reproduira pas la même chose pour ces
Jeux Olympiques moi j'ai pas de boule de
cristal mais en tout cas oui les
d'ailleurs on parlait des supporters
tout à l'heure les supporters de
Liverpool ont eu bon dos hein dans la
dans la bouche de Gérald harmanin parce
qu'on s'est rendu compte que c'est pas
tout à fait ça euh oui donc sur la
billéterie numérique notamment qui était
qui était exigé enfin on a vu comment ça
s'était passé pour le la finale de Ligue
des Champions à Paris donc billeterie
numérique ensuite formation des agents
de sécurité qui était totalement dépassé
et on avait appris qu'ils étaient
absolument pas formé donc il y a un
renforcement de de ce côté-là et
heureusement parce que rien que pour la
cérémonie d'ouverture 500000 personnes à
accueillir le long de la scène on va
avoir quelques défi devant nous quand
même mais qu'on peut garder le long de
la scène parce que des questions se
posent sur l'opportunité de de garder
une cérémonie le long de la scène un
pour des questions de risque terroriste
et et deux pour ces questions
d'organisation c'est une vraie
inquiétude il y a pas de plan B ça a été
confirmé il y a pas de plan B c'est
inimaginable d'ailleurs de transposer ce
qu'on imagine sur sur la le long de la
scène c'est une belle
idée toujours avec Emmanuel Macron c'est
bien de vérifier qu'elles sont faisable
avant ce serait pas mal là vous êtes
encore inquiet sur le fait que ce soit
vraiment bien fait oui c'est un peu
inquiétant merci Stéphane Piednoir merci
beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité
pendant cette première demi-heure dans